primero fue tianjin después de allianz y
ahora beijing la nueva variante omicron
ha llegado a la capital cuando sólo
faltan tres semanas para que empiecen
los juegos olímpicos de invierno y eso
explica la contundencia de las medidas
que ya se han tomado dos distritos han
cerrado los colegios y también se han
clausurado lugares turísticos tan
emblemáticos como el templo de lama en
el centro de la capital por ahora se ha
informado de un solo caso fue detectado
en la noche del sábado y esta mañana ya
se habían analizado a 16.000 personas
que en los últimos días habían
coincidido con ese positivo en varios
restaurantes centros comerciales o cines
se trata de una mujer que vive y trabaja
en el distrito universitario de javier y
que en las dos últimas semanas no había
salido de la ciudad así que se desconoce
cómo llego a contagiarse las autoridades
apuntaban esta mañana a una carta que
había recibido a principios de mes desde
canadá los expertos debaten sobre la
posibilidad de que el virus viaje
durante tanto tiempo en las superficies
pero esa posibilidad es defendida con
ahínco por china y se explica que todo
el personal de correos que había estado
en contacto con esa carta
ha sido puesto en cuarentena